[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 200 I forgot
to look it up nine 209 yes all right um
not prime it is not prime so that's the
end of that this I mean we could Factor
the thing but that's no fun so 11 by1 19
wow you are obviously prepared and I uh
I accept your factoring we have been too
often unprepared on the question of
prime to antagonize people is that right
okay well um then uh we have dispensed
with the issue we can move on to uh
paying the rent and uh substance you are
Dr Brett Weinstein and I am Dr Heather
hying and we are here as usual on
Wednesday we were not here last week uh
because you were also about which you
will speak a little bit I will speak um
and uh mostly we're going to be talking
at the end of the hour about uh places
you can find us and such but uh we
encourage you to go to locals uh always
uh we have the watch party going on we
release guest episodes early there
access to our Discord there but just
today uh We've released something very
exciting and uh there's going to be a
lot of act activity on locals uh in the
coming weeks you want to say something
about this sure um so Zach and I were
just down in Panama with Michael Yan who
was showing us various things including
the major migration across uh the Darian
Gap the Panama Canal situation
construction projects and Chris
Martinson was on this adventure as well
and on the last day of it he and I sat
down and started unpacking what it was
that we had seen trying to make sense of
it and I think you will find it quite um
fast fascinating uh for the moment it is
going to exist uh on locals alone in
part because an
unpacking where were you where so for
the people just listening uh Zach just
put up a picture of uh you and Chris
talking in front of a camera you've got
uh you've got an uncharacteristic look
going there you've got your rubber boots
which is absolutely mandatory Garb for L
and tropical rainforest but they're
folded down and you've zipped off the
bottom of your pants so you're not
feeling in too much uh too much risk
here where are you where is that that is
in the canal uh in a Cove there was a
particular Cove I wanted to go to but
the boat driver was reluctant so he
found us a Cove where we uh recorded a
little something um the podcast that
we've put up is actually uh after that
trip uh in the hotel and it goes in
great depth in terms of what we both
think um might be the meaning of the
things that Michael Leon showed us and
and Zach is editing some of the footage
that he took while you were down there
as well as well so there's there's
footage from the Daren and such right
yeah I think people are going to be
fascinated by this and I actually think
um you know these ideas are so new in
some cases that it takes a little while
to let them settle and see uh how
certain one is or whether something else
emerges but um I think this is going to
change people's view of what's taking
place pretty radically and it is I am
certain worth your time to go sign up at
locals and watch it I think it's about 3
hours so it's a lot of material but uh I
was wrong it's two hours it's two hours
oh good so you just saved an hour right
there um but it's uh it's not the way
that that's not the way that works
really I mean close enough um anyway
it's uh it's good stuff and um I don't
think I don't think anybody's going to
be bored by it cool um so we'll talk
just a little bit about some um some
Panama stuff here today uh and uh I want
to talk about misinformation I want to
talk to you about misinformation Brett
wow
yeah and um and uh ruling from ruling
not ruling a ruling from uh the uh
federal court in in Canada which is good
news it just came down and um I think
you have another something to talk about
as well but that's that's what we have
on uh on deck for today before and we're
not going to do a Q&A today but we
encourage like go to locals and and
check out this conversation between
Brett and Chris Martinson uh which
includes footage from their recent trip
um that that Zach took uh in in Panama
uh including the dairan um but first we
have ads we have sponsors um all of them
are awesome and uh we are excited for
them and they're out of order so I'm
just giving them in order I'm going to
give you that one wow um and they are
this week they are moink uh seed and
paleo Valley so without further Ado our
first sponsor this week is moink that's
moo plus oink m o i n k moink is a meat
subscription company on a mission to
save the Family Farm Mo's animals are
raised humanely their employees are paid
a living wage and the quality of their
product is better than anything you'll
find in a store founded by an eighth
generation farmer in a rural America who
happens also to be a woman moink
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild caught Alaskan
salmon directly to your door we love
everything about M and are so glad to
have them back as a sponsor the fact
that the is grass-fed and finished on
small farms the meat itself pork beef
lme chicken is all completely delicious
consider treating yourself or someone
else to some truly fabulous meat it's
grown humanely and with care and it is
fantastic for you moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did as a result
moink meat tastes like it should because
the Family Farm does it better and the
moink difference is a difference that
you can taste moink gives you total
control over the quality and source of
your food you choose the meat delivered
in every box from ribe eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
it is all fantastic and you can cancel
anytime you want the best bacon the best
steak the best chicken and the best
salmon you'll ever eat won't come from
the grocery store you'll only get it
from the family farm and independent
Alaskan fisherman and now you can when
you join the moink movement today keep
American farming going by signing up at
moink box.com Darkhorse right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one year of the
best ground beef you'll ever taste but
for a limited time that's m o i n k
box.com Darkhorse moink box.com
Dark Horse go now you won't regret it
and if I can just add you can if you
like meat
[Music]
try that's
mink you got to admit excellent pretty
good it's very good very good hard to to
spell very very good hard to spell but
yeah who needs spelling well go to moink
Fox yes exactly yeah that's excellent
our second sponsor this week is seed a
probiotic that really works if you've
tried probiotics before and got nothing
out of it try seed seriously it's
designed differently from other
probiotics it's designed better learn to
trust your gut if it's telling you
something is off it probably is seed
will help you get back on track seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall I take
seed every morning right after I brush
my teeth it's part of my routine now and
I love it one of the unique things about
seed is that it is basically double hold
with its capsule and capsule design
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon which is where you want it
that same design makes it resistant to
oxygen moisture and Heat heat meaning
that no Refrigeration is necessary
unlike most probiotics among other
things this means that you can travel
with it which I do so you can develop a
habit of taking seed to improve and
maintain your gut health and you don't
need to take a break from that habit
when you travel great gut health means
relief from digestive discomfort
bloating and intermittent constipation
seed also supports healthy gut immune
function the breakdown of fats and Seed
promotes clear smooth and healthy skin
helping you not just look but actually
be more healthy overall seed is a broad
spectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated with 24 clinically or
scientifically studied strains for
benefits across the body seed is also
free from 14 major classes of allergens
including but not limited to sugar
animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and
corn shellfish is actually included in
the animal products thing but it's worth
a separate mention sure yeah of course I
think so uh seeds daily symbiotic
supports gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis people who use
seed often report improvements to their
digestive to their digestive function in
2 4 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse to redeem 25% off
your first month of seeds DS1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse at checkout hate to
disappoint no sound effect for that one
we have one more ad I don't think we
want a sound effect for probiotics you
really don't um there is no sound effect
because healthy got there you go all
right uh our final sponsor this week is
Paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a huge
range of products from supplements like
fish row and or organ complex grass-fed
bone broth protein and superfood bars
everything we've tried from them has
been terrific including their golden
milk made with loads of turmeric but
we're going to talk today about their
beef sticks the beef in these delicious
snacks comes from small American-owned
Farms that practice rotational grazing
paleo Valley's beef sticks are 100%
grass-fed and finished entirely organic
and naturally fermented 100% grass-fed
beef is more nutritious than grain-fed
beef in many ways including that it
contains more calcium magnesium
potassium zinc phosphorus betacarotene
and iron it is also utterly delicious if
you're thinking that paleo Valley's beef
sticks are like slim gyms you're wrong
one thing unlike slim gyms paleo
Valley's beef scks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts for
another paleo Valley's beef sticks are
actually good for you ingredients hiding
in most beef sticks include and jerky
include MSG hormones hydrogenated o oils
and brominated vegetable oil which if
you're wondering what that is it was
first patented as a flame
retardant you ever seen a beef stick not
catch fire you know why and now it's in
a lot of food not if you buy paleo
valley though furthermore unlike other
meat uh snacks paleo valy uses natural
fermentation to preserve its beef sticks
this gives the beef sticks a long shelf
life without the use of harmful acids
and chemicals and with the added benefit
of contributing to a healthy gut paleo
Valley beef sticks are also keto
friendly and make a great protein-rich
snack to grab when you're on the go like
running out the door for a meeting or
going on a bike ride or hike paleo
Valley doesn't cut Corners they Source
only the highest quality ingredients and
are passionate not only about human
health but environmental restoration and
Animal Welfare as well and they're a
family-owned company try paleo Valley's
beef sticks today and you'll be glad
that you did head over to paleo
valley.com Darkhorse for 15% off your
first
order all right
um
maybe we should start by talking about
misinformation all right let's talk
about her um okay I didn't know we were
talking about her but go for
it well played um no no misinformation
okay good um so um hat tip to a Twitter
account called Green leap forward. WTF
um uh on Twitter for pointing me to uh
an analysis in excuse me an analysis in
Washington Post here it is you can show
my screen here um by a guy named Philip
bump called doing your own research is a
good way to end up being wrong now I
don't know why the picture uh came in
blurry here it's of January 6 because of
course it is um but it doesn't matter
it's not it's not germine to the
discussion um I'm going to read just a
little bit from this uh wo oped and then
um go in some depth into the research
that he is basing this conclusion on uh
which was published at the very end of
2023 and which has a supplementary
information Section 105 pages long most
of which I managed to get through and it
is rather remarkable um how it is these
researchers and then an anal an analyst
at the Washington Post managed to
conclude um that what you definitely
should not do if you're trying to
determine what is true is try to figure
it out for yourself so
um bump writes in Washington Post the
last week or so when was it it was uh
January 17th there is an outsize
appetite for derogatory counterintuitive
or anti-institutional assessments of the
world around us this is in part because
alleged SC scandals are interesting and
in part because Americans like to view
themselves as independent analysts of
the world around us not what's missing
from
that it might also be in part uh because
because uh the institutions have
dramatically failed us and uh anyone who
doesn't think so has not been paying
attention that's just one other
possibility that is not mentioned here
the extent of institutional suc
suckitude is conspicuously left off the
list of causal agents of the reason for
the outsized appetite for anti
anti-institutional assessments outsized
outsized yeah outsized okay so here's
just a couple of paragraphs from again
this is the Washington Post uh analyst's
version of uh
review of This research that I'll go
into although conventional wisdom
suggests uh oh this is he's actually
quoting here the the the research
although conventional wisdom suggests
that searching online when evaluating
misinformation will produce belief in it
there is little empirical evidence to
evaluate this claim the authors wrote
instead they continued quote we present
consistent evidence that online search
to evaluate the truthfulness of false
news articles actually increases the
probability of believing them end quote
later they summarize the process quote
when individuals search online about
misinformation they are more likely to
be exposed to lower quality information
than when individuals search about True
News so that's that's that actually
makes some sense that if you are
actually trying to find things that
assess whether or not things that are
false are true there's likely to be less
information about it out there because
it's not true and you will run into uh
lower quality information because the
thing you're actually looking for isn't
true well but that hinges
on that hinges on the assessment of what
is true and what is false being accurate
right the the methological flaw here is
well you haven't you hav heard anything
about you haven't heard the methodology
yet um and quote those who are exposed
to lowquality information are more
likely to believe false and misleading
news stories to be true relative to
those who are
not look for info see bad info accept
the bad info so that's bumps uh summary
the mechanism is explored at length but
in short false claims are other rumors
often generate fewer hits on Google
meaning Searchers are more likely to
encounter unreliable information that
aligns with their assumptions then he
says the paper is dense Benton's summary
is useful I decided not to go to
Benton's summary whoever that is I
decided to go to the paper it is dense
they did a lot of stuff and there's a
you know there's a lot of data there's a
lot of they do five different
experiments you can give me my screen
back please five different experiments
um all of which um are basically and
then and we'll walk through the paper a
bit and then really where the the devil
in the details is in the supplement
supplementary information which is so
often where it is with research right um
but basically what they did was they
recruited people to look at
articles um and then they asked some of
those people to um do their own Google
searches or however it is that they
wanted to do it uh to to try to figure
out if these articles that they had read
were in fact true and um and see if
their conclusions before and after they
did their own research had changed um
and after they had done their own
research participants were asked to rank
how true the article was on a 7. scale
and I actually have a um image here
which I've closed down let me just find
of this um this will this will become
relevant later uh the seven-point
ordinal scale um that they use you can
show here the seven-point ordinal
veracity scale to determine how
confident a respondent is of their
evaluation we ask respondents the
following question um it's you know it's
of course it has to be it's qualitative
it's it's seven points they don't they
at least don't call it um they don't
they don't exactly call it quantitative
but they're pretending that it is
they're asking people to give an
assessment of um how true they think the
article that they've read is uh after um
after they have evaluated it by doing
sort of standard googly search things uh
and I definitely need my screen back
here
um so
um that requires for so what what
they're doing is they're having these
respondents assess via Google whether or
not something is true or not and then
describe whether or not they think this
article is true or
not but how do the researchers know it's
true how how are the researchers
assessing truth these things are
published out there they're articles so
um first off let's talk a little bit
about how they Source the Articles and
then how they Source the truth because
that's awesome I mean if they have if
they have a beat on the truth we should
just be going to these guys abs freaking
absolutely imagine that you could just
have a central repository of Truth where
you could go and you just know whether
something was accurate or not it's
freaking awesome that's fantastic yeah I
mean I'm really glad Washington Post
brought this to our attention it's
fantastic research
um the entire just to not to belabor the
point but I'm going to keep doing it um
the entire research hinges is
on okay you think this you respondent
you experimental subject um but only we
actually know if the thing is true so we
get to assess whether or not uh you have
gotten closer or farther from the truth
uh because we know the truth and you
don't okay so where did they get the
Articles first of all and then how did
they how did they assess the truth of
the Articles um they used five types of
media outlets and they do include a list
um although and I'm not it's just long
and
um I'll show you a little bit of it
maybe but the five types of media
Outlets are mainstream liberal
mainstream conservative lowquality
liberal lowquality conservative and
lowquality of no political bent I've met
some lowquality
liberals not lowquality people of all
political Stripes strip there but thing
I want to point out there is um that the
Counterpoint this this binary that
they've created is mainstream and low
quality mhm like that's that's their
that's their binary that's their categor
categorization scheme and in fact when
you go in and you look at their
assessment which again I haven't told
you yet how they've assessed these but
you look at their assessment of the
Articles uh that they were finding in
mainstream Outlets of both liberal and
conservative uh bents uh amazingly
wellow they're just all true now not
entirely but almost all true whereas the
low quality ones well no that's you know
that's where the apparently that's where
the hits the fan
uh this would seem to be somewhat um
circular in its its reasoning the
topology would seem to be and again I
haven't yet told you how is it that
truth is being assessed but Ma if
mainstream is true is is found to be
more true based on what now um and that
that gives us the answer to how it is
they decided oh it's mainstream versus
low quality because mainstream is
inherently high quality this
incidentally this was this was published
before but um the LA Times just uh fired
a bunch of journalists because they're
either going under or about to and you
know if if people aren't questioning the
mainstream outlets at this point I don't
know I don't know what go on well
there's so many ways in which this is
absurd but one of them is the number of
places where the mainstream has flipped
positions is shocking it invalidates the
methodology straight away well no
because I haven't told you the
methodology that that does not
invalidate the methodology inherently um
but it could depending on what the
methodology is well I'm interested to
hear but it's hard to imagine how if the
mainstream flips 180 degrees if we go
from you know covid is definitely zentic
in origin to uh lab leak is probable
right but but so I am telling you that
in their in their results they find that
the mainstream tends to be true um they
did not say they did not make the
obvious error of saying oh well
mainstream is true and everything else
is low quality that would I mean
that hopefully would not have gotten
published but um but what did get
published is um frankly more dangerous
because it's just slightly more cryptic
so here it is uh the article online
searches to evaluate misinformation can
increase its perceived veracity that's
the title of the article published at
the very end of 2023 and I'm going to
just read a few uh
a few bits from it before explaining
more depth what what they found we find
that the search effect is concentrated
among individuals for whom search
engines return lower quality
information uh uh our findings highlight
the need for media literacy programs to
ground their recommendations in
empirically tested
strategies I don't know who there is
here so this actually strikes me as
potentially very very evil frankly um
but I cannot figure out what they mean
by
there here we go for all of so they did
five sets of experiments they're all
basically they're very similar they're
not the same but they're very similar
for all five studies we used a pipeline
which was also pre-registered to select
popular articles from both mainstream
and non-mainstream media sources and
then distribute them to respondents and
professional fact Checkers parenthesis a
full explanation of this process is
provided in the methods we'll get there
and the methods are not of course you
notice the order that in which um many
primary literature science articles are
published has now been mixed the methods
come at the end at the very end because
it's like admitted that no one wants to
see them anyway like you actually have
to dig for the methods that's that's
that's an admission that this is not
science I that's the case here as well
the methods are at the very end and then
a lot of the methods actually the
details are in the supplementary
information which it actually took me a
while to find and I'm good at this well
it it uh it goes to what we have said on
a number of topics where something is
designed to get you not to pay attention
totally um and designed not to get you
not to pay attention uh is a red flag
that you may be surrendering something
in what you're not looking at that might
matter a great deal right Owen I I don't
even know what the conversation might
have sounded like to justify this like
oh it's
it's just so much text in the middle
don't we want to get people to the
results like there's no results without
methods like the the the the reason that
the order has has been uh you know
summary which is a little bit of a cheap
but like summary up top and then you
introduce the question and and the
hypothesis and then you explain what you
did to test the hypothesis and then you
get to the results that were emanating
from those methods and then the
discussion of those results if the
methods come last it puts the light of
the whole thing and frankly brings into
question whether or not you were
actually doing um the scientific process
in the order in which it must be done in
order to actually get results as opposed
to just new observations in the first
place I mean it really does you know
obviously the order could
be you know this it could be an innocent
stupidity but it's all over the place
it's increasingly all over the place if
you have a phony field that is its
purpose is effectively to um
rationalize mainstream thought then of
course method would be an afterthought
because conclusion you know the only
thing the method can do is upend the
conclusion that you're trying to reach
right y um so you could imagine that
just cognitively they are um
telegraphing something that uh is pretty
shocking yes you know that it would they
wouldn't notice that this was an
absurdity right it's like it's it's it's
a cart before the horse kind of thing
mhm um that if you were you know working
backwards from a conclusion you know of
course you wouldn't get why it mattered
right um one more a couple more things
from the actual the main the main paper
as opposed to the supplementary
information um a key challenge was
establishing the veracity of the
Articles directly after publication a
period during which assessments from
factchecking organizations were not
likely to be
available to this end we sent out the
Articles to be evaluated concurrently by
a group of six professional fact
Checkers from leading National Outlets
the fact Checkers could rate articles as
true false or misleading or could not
determine each article was then labeled
as either true okay that's not even the
worst of it you ready for the next
sentence each article was then labeled
as either true false or misleading or
could not be determined based on the
modal fact Checker
evaluation so they and they used most of
these they had up to six but most of
them had four or five most of them had
five fact Checkers these fact checkers
go in within 24 hours of something being
published these are professional fact
Checkers so they must know what they're
doing they ascribe one of three one of
three conclusions true false or
misleading or couldn't determine and
then whichever of those three
conclusions is most common because
that's what the mode means is most
common among a crew of five fact
Checkers becomes the truth right that
article was true because three of five
fact Checkers said it was two
professional fact Checkers which already
is no Arbiter of truth may have said
false or misleading but if three out of
five said it was that's the mode that's
the truth and any person who read that
article and went looking for themselves
and went oh I don't I don't think so
well if three out of five fact Checkers
said so you're wrong buddy and I mean
the the degree to which this is
a what's the polite term for a fractal
cluster but how are they assessing
the veracity of these things they are
doing they are engaged in some kind of
searching themselves which if we are to
believe the conclusion of this paper
which preceded the method then suggests
that they may be misled by whatever
research it is that they did I got
somewh detail on this for oh yeah no a
fair bit actually here's one here's
another place in the paper determining
the veracity of articles H one of the
key challenges in this study was
determining the veracity of the article
and the period directly after
publication I should say so whereas many
studies use Source quality as a proxy
for article quality not all articles
from suspect news sites are actually
false thanks for that again like but the
inverse is true all articles from
mainstream sites are actually true you
you don't even say that other Studies
have relied on professional fact
checking organizations such as Snopes or
PolitiFact to identify false or
misleading stories from these sources
however the use of evaluations from
these organizations is impossible when
sourcing articles in real time because
we have no way of knowing whether these
articles will ever be checked by such
organizations again they didn't not use
Snopes or PolitiFact because they
recognized that Snopes and PolitiFact
are ideologically captured organizations
they didn't use them because they
weren't sure that Snopes or PolitiFact
would get around to it yeah so they had
these these poor authors had to do
something else as an alternative
evaluation mechanism we hired six
professional fact Checkers from leading
National media
organizations to also assess each
article during the same 24-hour period
is response so also these people work
for the so-called mainstream news
outlets they are of course more inclined
to think that the Articles from the
mainstream news outlets are true in
studies four and five again they did
five um different slightly different
sets of experiments in studies four and
five given the onset of in studies four
and five given the onset of the pandemic
and the potential harm caused by medical
misinformation the professional fact
Checkers rated the Articles 24 hours
before the respondents so that we could
show respondents the fact Checkers
ratings of each article immediately
after completion of this
survey these professional fact Checkers
were recruited from a diverse group of
reputable Publications none of the fact
Checkers were employed by publication
included in our studies to ensure no
conflicts of interest and were paid $10
per article the modal response of the
professional fact Checkers yield 37
false or misleading 102 true and 16
indeterminate articles from study 1 give
me my screen back for a second and let
me show
you from hold on a second yeah this is
from the supplemental uh materials fact
Checker agreement um this is you know
statistically convoluted inter rer
reliability statistics for fact Checker
evaluations of Articles and studies they
evaluated 265 articles percentage of
articles with unanimous agreement was
44.6% okay my screen back one more time
uh let allow me if I may uh to read a
couple of paragraphs from my very first
Natural Selections piece which was
called fact Checkers aren't scientists
uh when we were in the middle of you in
particular being defamed by so-called
fact Checkers PolitiFact which is
partnered with Facebook to be their fact
checking arm has a six tier rating
system for their truth ometer I didn't
make that up that's what they call it
the most egregious rating the one that
they say they only deliver to the least
true statements is pants on fire this is
described as being applied to something
that is not accurate and makes a
ridiculous claim indeed pants on fire
canote something worse than a complete
untruth it suggests a lie a lie liar
liar pants on fire goes the childhood
taunt those statements earning a pants
on fire rating by PolitiFact must be
pretty awful and so must be the people
saying such things well guess what
that's not how science works but then
ptif is not a scientific organization
nor are fact Checkers scientists any
organization that conflates the veracity
of a statement with the intention of a
person making the statement as
PolitiFact does with its pants on fire
rating is not even pretending to hide
its anti-scientific bent here's one
example of where they applied this
rating to the labl hypothesis in
September of 2020 of the possibility
that SARS K2 leaked from a lab
PolitiFact wrote the claim is inaccurate
and ridiculous rate it pants on
fire the scientific evidence has not
changed since then but the political
winds have and by May of 2021 PolitiFact
had changed their minds saying in an
editor's note that they have removed
this fact check from their database as
the claim is now understood to be more
widely disputed you don't say that is of
course proof that factchecking doesn't
work exactly that is proof that
factchecking does not does not work so
um so as does as does the fact that the
fact Checker set to the task in this
experiment did not agree exactly like
that that actually completely stunned me
um that they they any article on which
their fact Checkers of dubious fact
checking capability how about um any
article on which they did not agree
should not have been included right by
by you know just to consistent with
their own still flawed but their their
own metrics but but no so there's a lot
in the supplemental information there
are um a lot here's I just started
looking through the headlines the
hundreds of headlines in 265 articles
that they had uh the both the fact
Checkers there's Arbiters of Truth and
their hapless respondents who sometimes
believed things that weren't true um
went through so this is for um St 2 and
three headlines for articles chosen from
the lowquality conservative news stream
and so you know they they looked at
lowquality liberal newsstream although
they couldn't find as many lowquality
liberal Outlets funny they just didn't
have as many um but they had equal
numbers of uh mainstream conservative
and mainstream liberal outlets and a lot
of uh low quality Outlets that they
couldn't quite decide what they were
um let's just look at the top one
here why are volcanoes all over the
globe suddenly shooting giant clouds of
Ash miles into the air that's the
headline from January 13th 20120 modal
fact Checker rating again we don't know
if that means three four five we don't
like it means just a majority of fact
Checkers of whom there were probably
only five on this said yeah this is
false or
misleading the topic they say is science
and then interestingly the lean of the
article they give as
neutral so they the meth methods and the
supplemental information does not
actually give complete information they
do not tell me which that they do not
give links to or tell me exactly which
article this is but they tell me the
headline they tell me when it was
published uh so if you will give me my
screen back for a moment um what I find
when I look uh uh and you can put this
back up is this which I suspect is not
the original places this article was
published but exactly this um headline
uh one day later why are volcanoes all
over the globe suddenly shooting giant
clouds of Ash miles into the air January
14th 2020 it's possible this is a
totally different article but when I
look for various keywords and such from
from the time um I find I find a few
articles like this but nothing is
anywhere close in terms of this headline
and this is the headline of the article
that they say they looked
at obviously this is clear to you but it
is obscene that that they would deny you
the ability to know that you were
evaluating the correct article because
you could invalidate their method by
discovering that things that they had
rated as false or misleading are
actually true by doing your own research
which would of course invalidate their
premise
right I am clearly likely to be suckered
into believing misinformation BEC You
know why you know how you can tell
because I'm doing my own research oh boy
yeah yeah so this one which again I've
I've given all the caveats I think I I
can about you know whether or not this
is actually the article that they had
their their people look at um claims um
that there have there certainly has been
there certainly hasn't been a lack of
seismic activity so far in 2020 so when
I go if I can have my screen back again
for a moment when I go to their
to
uh actually I'm just going to read this
off my screen when I go to the links in
that article uh I find several volcanic
eruptions within a couple of weeks of
that article being published and I
checked several of them and just three
are so this was published January 14th
2020 the headline is um again why are
volcanoes all over the globe suddenly
shooting giant clouds of Ash miles into
the air which the a modal number of fact
Checkers um not to be less than three or
more than five uh assessed as a falser
misleading
article in Alaska volcano Sheldon in the
uans on January 7th erupted uh sending
Ash 19,000 ft into the air in the
Philippines volcano tall on January 12th
erupted uh shooting Ash and steam 6 to9
miles vertically into the air and in
Peru on the same day January 12th
volcano sabankaya
erupted uh shooting Ash 24,000 ft
vertically into the air
so patently this can't be this false and
misleading article can't be about the
the fals and misleading nature of it
can't be about were there several
volcanoes all over the world shooting
ashes shooting Ash vertically several
miles into the air they were and I I
checked those claims against other
sources but the sources for two of those
that I just read the sources linked in
the original article were from the
relevant volcanologist or GE geological
places for the regions where they were
so it was actually primary right there
in the article so that raises the
question of what might be false or
misleading because the the vast majority
of that article is just like here's
another one here's another one here's
another one here's when it erupted it
went Skyhigh Ash miles into the air so
the only place it could be false
is why but that's not a well worked out
piece of science so that's a that's not
a well-worked out piece of science B the
article doesn't make a claim the
headline says why and then uh and the
guy starts with like well I've been
talking about this and he ends with
um basically suggestive language around
I think something bigger is a foot I
think there's something bigger a foot
and he has he has a link he doesn't even
say this but he has a link in the
article to granted a like Christian
apocalypse site saying you know this is
what all this means that's not even in
the article now again I'm not 100% sure
that this is the article that they that
they were assessing but um REM remember
excuse me remember that 7o ordinal scale
having read this article as a respondent
in as an experimental subject going
doing just what I did you know or you
know I don't know maybe less maybe more
and saying well where there volcanoes
shooting Ash you know miles in the air
recently all over the world oh well
there were there were so when you were
asked then to I'll just put this up
again
uh if you then asked having read that
article and having done research on its
veracity and now you're asked okay now
that you've evaluated the article we are
interested you're interested in the
strength of your opinion please rank the
article on the following scale from
definitely not true to definitely
true when I read that article I think I
don't know that I trust the guy writing
it and I certainly don't buy the one
link that I find at the end that goes to
a Christian apocalypse site but that's
not even in the article the only claims
he actually makes in the article right
just something's H something's happening
something big is happening I think
something big is a foot and the evidence
for that something big is happening
claim is frankly irrefutable
so if I were asked if I was a respondent
here on in in this crazy piece of
research definitely not true to
definitely true I might if I were being
a little bit I think frankly now I I
think that's a little careless um be
like Oh I'm not sure like the guy
doesn't seem totally trustworthy but
everything that he claims that he
actually claims is true I might have
given it a six I think I should have
given it a seven because that's
definitely true everything that he
actually says
that is fact-based all the claims that
are factual all the claims that are
factual are in fact true and fact-based
um but remember what our friends at um
the factchecking organizations
claimed uh which
was again why are volcanoes all over the
globe suddenly shooting giant clouds of
Ash miles into the air modal fact
Checker rating false or
misleading isach well I would just uh
not not that I think that they are
actually thinking this carefully but
just to give the devil is due y uh my
guess is that they are saying the false
or misleading part is that there's no
pattern that this is more than in
previous years that's the part that at
least from what I've seen it also makes
it very hard to evaluate because it's
like well he this guy does go give
specific links for the things that have
happened this year yeah they they have a
lot of Wiggle gr but my guess is that's
where they are able to but then they but
they are inferring so you know why are
volcanoes all over the globe suddenly
shooting giant clouds of Ash miles into
the air suddenly is a little bit you
know enthusiastic it's it's that's a
that's a editorial claim uh and there is
an implied hypothesis that this is
happening now and it hasn't happened
before right he doesn't even really like
it's implied it's an implied hypothesis
suddenly well that's what I just said
this the suddenly is is the is the
editorial here um so my my point really
is with regard to
this how could you as an experimental
subject have assessed this because there
is in the headline and in the last
paragraph of the piece an at least a
implied hypothesis of there's something
bigger going on here right but the vast
majority of the article is just here's
another here's one here's another one
here's another one here here it is like
and it's not it's you it's mostly pafic
but it's not entirely he doesn't say
that but you know I was looking like
maybe it's not all over the world like
no it's all over the world like there
were a bunch of volcanoes so I would
also point out that the suddenly is in
the title very good chance he didn't
write the title so like at some at some
of who cares right I get it but but but
the idea how how are you what what does
true to not true mean right like what
did the fact Checkers assess that they
went false misleading when what the the
fact Checkers were told true they got
three options true false or misleading
or uh undetermined couldn't tell right
whereas
the experimental
subjects weren't offered a misleading to
not misleading option they were only
offered a true to not true option yeah
so the very like even if fat Checkers
were actually Arbiters of Truth and even
if somehow even though they're Arbiters
of Truth a lot of times they get it
wrong and the mode is still the right
the mode of their responses is still the
right way to do it even if those things
were true which neither of them are
still you have to give them the same
task as you give the respondents you
don't get to offer the fact Checkers
true or false or misleading and then
only offer the respondents true to not
true what do you think it's it's not a
legitimate scale and frankly with
articles like that being
included maybe there's something
misleading there because we haven't been
told what's happened in past years and
the hypothesis is implied that this is
happening more now but but in terms of
what is simply displayed on in the
article it's true so I'm sorry true and
not true doesn't fit well I
mean I do have the sense that this is
driving you crazy because it isn't what
it masquerades
as which is science right right but that
this is there's now an
ecosystem of I don't even know what to
call it so remember the definition of
malformation
malformation are things based in truth
that cause you to distrust Authority
yeah this is the inverse of that this is
Malin information to the negative one
this is fiction that causes you to trust
Authority right this is pseudo
quantification shoty
methodology um it's nonsense it's a
failure of deductive logic that assumes
access to uh effectively um a
Divine uh slate of of truths yes which
simply doesn't exist and everybody knows
it doesn't exist so the point is if you
were if you I think it's also important
that people understand the relationship
between this and cargo cult science yes
so cargo cult science um is a very
famous piece written by Fineman who
describes um the show notes vast
scientific
failures that follow a pattern where
people people get involved in going
through motions that appear scientific
And discussing things in ways that sound
scientific but without doing the
philosophically proper um work to make
their conclusions Justified resulting in
false things taking on the veneer of
science right so we have this um
uh censorship complex that has decided
that it wants to prevent us from
discovering certain things by silencing
voices by declaring certain claims
fictional it has been embarrassed again
and again by us small fries out here in
podcast land who have demonstrated that
lots of things that have been declared
pants on fire and worse not mainstream
at all must be low quality right it's
insane and you know it runs a foul of uh
this principle which I deploy sometimes
which is that every great idea starts as
a minority of one right if you're going
to decide that you can just check with
people as to whether or not something's
true then you're basically saying that
we're never going to learn anything new
again because we're going to keep
shutting down people who come up with
something that we haven't figured out
yet you know while they're still in the
minority so there's no method here
there's none right this is uh High te
sophistry yep and you know it's like
you're damned if you do do you get drawn
in as you have and explain all of the
insanity buried Haven exped all of it
well do you do you set yourself the task
of saying here is why this paper which
claims something some conclusion is
actually not sufficient to reach that
conclusion I think it's the reason I
think it's important is because uh you
know there's a good chance this paper
just could have gotten created and
disappeared no one would have read it
ever there's a decent chance that it
could have gotten grabbed by one of
these uh you know new organizations uh
whose business it is to make sure that
no one disagrees with the the
Orthodoxy um and what actually happened
was it got picked up by uh you know
someone who calls himself an analyst at
Washington Post who admits in the
article that he wrote uh that it's dense
and he doesn't admit it but he you know
he
basically it seems to me that he likely
didn't read the actual research um but
it also seems to me that he's
ideologically captured and he wanted to
believe what he wanted to believe and so
when you when you actually go in I
didn't I didn't know what I was going to
find I mean I my my bias going in was I
did not expect it to be uh brilliantly
done and I expected frankly I expected
there to be some um some more more games
played with the mainstream liberal
versus mainstream conservative outlets
and they look pretty clean on that like
they you know they have their fact
Checkers coming up with you know oh
those things are you know basically the
fact Checkers are caring less about
liberal versus conservative as
mainstream versus uh little guys that's
what the fact Checkers were biasing
towards and you know you could say you
could argue no you got it wrong you got
it backwards the fact Checkers found
that because the mainstream media
sources are more likely to be true are
more likely to be reporting actual truth
than the than the so-called lowquality
sources and you know maybe if you
control for if if if you recognize that
there are just a hell of a lot more uh
smaller media sources yes there will be
more things that are wrong just based on
the numbers but the idea that at this
point you are trusting the mainstream
because it is mainstream and you've
pulled fact Checkers who don't work for
any of the organizations that they're
actually including in this research but
they work for like these are Prof
professional fact Checkers who are
working for mainstream Outlets who are
being asked to go in and assess the
veracity of of articles that you know
with regard to co what what most people
thought was clearly wrong some of us
were saying that at the time some of us
were missing some of those things and
getting other things
but
why how is this still happening and this
was you know this was sent to me
precisely um with s of the the line
something like you know this this again
this is still happening it's important
because this is still happening because
they're still up to these tricks well of
course they're still up to these tricks
there's an industry
There's an actual industry that is
basically creating work designed to
sideline people who keep embarrassing
Goliath right and so that industry has
set about the task of making things look
scientific and this is not an article
designed to be read this is an article
designed to be cited right that's the
difference is and Y we see this in all
over the place we see this now with
respect to things like the randomized
controlled Tri that supposedly proved
that Ivor maon didn't work once you get
into the details of what these things
were they were incapable of testing the
question properly at all they were
designed to fail right but what you
really need is the headline that says
this has now been tested and we've
established a fact yep now you could
look at the claim that they had a method
for figuring out whether or not um this
worked and you could spot on its face
there will be no method because there is
no mechanism for figuring out when
somebody has a belief that uh seems
scandalously off now that turns into the
mainstream belief 5 years later right
there's no method there couldn't be a
method what would that method even be
the only conceivable method would
involve a very long period of time in
which you saw whether if we do this test
today 25 years from now did the fact
that we thought was a fact stand up or
did the facts that we think are facts
not stand up right if you did a very
long experiment you could conceivably
figure out some sort of a trend but
you're still not establishing whether
something is true what you're
establishing is how stable it's become
whether the interpretation flips back
and forth or stabilizes into one thing
over time y so of course this wasn't
going to have a method because there
isn't one there's no conceivable method
well no I I disagree there is a method
and I mean this this maybe is is my main
point there is precisely a method and so
if we speak in precisely
and say there's no method like they're
be able to say ah of course there's a
method you can see it I don't mean that
there's no method in the paper I mean
there's no method to do what they claim
there is a me I I do think that we need
to be precise when we can about uh the
methodology which is a buried B abstruse
and C even even so even this in the
supplementary information there is not
everything that you would need to fully
assess uh what is going on here um but
even even here uh it is it is not
possible for that method to have done
what it claims to have done right and
indeed no method could right in fact we
it is imp it is impossible to ask this
question given humans there is a method
we have to work in this direction and
it's called science yeah right sorry let
me uh change right just it's impossible
to ask this question given humans in the
short term right right well let's put it
this way the strange of Science in
establishing what is factually true is
that it does not claim anything as uh
permanent right right there's nothing it
can conclude that couldn't be upended by
better information later so the point is
science it's its very strength is that
it admits this method can't be right
that there is a way of establishing what
is true and that is formulating a
hypothesis it makes predictions if those
predictions are born out an experiment
and no other hypothesis predicts those
same things then you have a theory that
doesn't make it permanent it means it is
still up for falsification given more
evidence which you know you don't have
to know very much of the history of
science to see the pattern right right
so anyway science is the method and
they're trying to replace it with social
garbage right this is this is this is
people who really don't know how to
think doing a different job which is
trying to give the veneer of science to
things that don't deserve it that's
right um I do want to share a couple
more sure uh just for this is again from
the supplemental information of this um
this paper that was published at the end
of
2023 um just the top one I there's some
weird type font thing there um from May
late May
2020 remember late May 2020 things were
weird things seemed like they were as
bad as they could get and then George
Floyd died and things weren't even
stupider your immunity passport future
begins to materialize as Airlines call
for digital ID tracking
systems well the modal fact Checkers
declared that false or misleading and uh
and that was a a science article
apparently um One More in here
uh oh Chinese from June of 2020 Chinese
scientist escorted out of Canadian
biolab sent deadly viruses to Wuhan fals
or
misleading
okay from May of 2020 again again fouchi
says he wears a mask to be a symbol of
what you should be
doing that's right it is true and the
topic is science and lean of the article
is
neutral just to show what class what
what is been classified as science and
what seems
neutral oh my goodness and one
more um this is from let's see I've lost
the thing that I
wanted to do from this
well this one June 2020 CDC more
Americans drinking cleaning products
than ever before that had no mode that
was one of the very few where the fact
Checkers um actively actively disagreed
um oh this is the one I wanted to show
line four from table
S14 um forced vaccinations will control
your life warrants religious liberty
group that's labeled false or misleading
and also in science and I want end there
because um one other thing that I wanted
to do before we move into talking about
Panama is um so again that was forced
vaccinations will control your life
Warren's religious liberty group and
it's labeled falser misleading by the
mode of uh by you know three four or
five fact Checkers who were asked to
assess this uh which strikes me as uh
interesting in light of uh what the
Canadian federal court did this week the
Canadian federal court this week
declared that Trudeau's use of the
emergencies act during the uh trucker
Convoy and after it um was
unconstitutional which is remarkable so
um thanks to Dan arand who sent this to
me he's the Canadian Patriot uh whose
letter documenting um the early stages
of the trucker Convoy um and the mood of
the country the mood of Canada and how
it changed this truckers Convoy began um
he sent that to us in late January of
2020 and I published that on natural in
Natural Selections and it became one of
my most widely um read and appreciated
uh
pieces
um he Dan sent me to an article in True
North news which I'll post um but I also
took a look at the original ruling uh
which of course as you might imagine is
kind of long and um and and legal e uh
but hold on this is not no this is it
okay so I'm just going to read a little
bit from the conclusion uh again from
the federal court um in in Canada uh
which has found that the Emer the use of
Trudeau's use of the emergency act
during the trer Convoy um was illegal
was
unconstitutional this is remarkable
writes the judge at the outset of these
proceedings while I had not reached a
decision on any of the four applications
I was leaning to the view that the
decision to invoke the emergencies Act
was reasonable I considered the events
that occurred in Ottawa and other
locations in January and February 2022
went beyond legitimate protest and
reflected an unacceptable breakdown of
public order I had and continued to have
considerable sympathy for those in
government who were confronted with the
situation had I been at their tables at
that time I may have agreed that it was
necessary to invoke the act and I
acknowledge that in conducting judicial
review of that decision I am revisiting
that time with the benefit of hindsight
and a more extensive record of the facts
and law than that which was before the
GIC GIC is the governor and Council
which is the body that made the
decision my preliminary view of the
reasonableness of the decision may have
prevailed following the hearing to
excellent advocacy on the part of
council for the Attorney General of
Canada had I not taken the time to
carefully deliberate about the evidence
and submissions particularly those of
the ccla and CCF that is the
uh can't find it because oh here um the
ccla is the Canadian civil liberties
Association and the CCF is the Canadian
Constitution Foundation they're two um
public organizations he writes uh the
judge writes their participation in
these proceeding ings has demonstrated
again the value of public interest
litigant especially in presenting
informed legal argument this case may
not have turned out the way it has
without their involvement as the private
interest litigants were not as capable
of marshalling the evidence and argument
in support of their applications just a
on a side here he actually um refused to
I'm not a lawyer I don't know the
language he refused to hear several of
the private um litigants he decided they
did not have standing um they had
certainly had cases and they had
grievances um and you know to to my
train legal eyed they looked legitimate
um but he had he he said he declared
several of the private litigant not not
did not have standing a couple of the
private ones did um but it was as he
says here it was the public litigant um
who whose testimony really changed his
mind and remarkable for this judge have
said that here I have concluded that the
decision to issue the proclamation does
not bear the Hallmarks of reasonableness
justification transparency and
intelligibility and was not justified in
relation to the relevant factual and
legal constraint that were required to
be taken into consideration and thus uh
the public order of emergency was not um
the the conditions were not satisfied
and there never should have been a
public order emergency so that's
remarkable yeah uh in many regards one
it lets you see how much we must have
vigorous public debate because
effectively if you had successfully
demonized uh the position if if the
sensors had been successful it's not
obvious that the challenges necessary
would have reached this judge and this
judge would still have the inverse view
right of whether or not this was uh was
uh tolerable and justifiable yeah I mean
his characterization of the protest in
here in the in in this finding in which
he reverses in which he says no that was
unconstitutional guys you can't have
done that um in that document his
description of what happened in the
truckers conf in Ottawa uh strikes me as
practically the opposite of everything
that I that I know to have happened not
having been able to be there because
again not vaccinated but right like I I
told you at the time and I actually said
this uh on another podcast recently like
this is the only protest that I have
ever known about that I really really
desperately wanted to be at and of
course in part the point was like no you
can't come yeah yes you You unvaccinated
Foreigner cannot come into our
country yeah well so so you know
unacceptable breakdown of public order
just you know the people that I know
including Dan arand who were on the
ground there um you know that's that's
not what was being reported by the
people who were involved in in the
actual protest in the trucker Convoy but
this judge had that in his head because
that was what was being uh reported in
the mainstream media across the board
and he changed his mind and he he he
reversed this and that's amazing so
thank goodness for the the uh C Heroes
who stood up I was thinking in
particular of via FR who I didn't know
before this but um his reporting on the
ground put the lie to the mainstream
story of what was going on there and and
we had photographer danap Ponte whose
photographs I I published some of he was
just he was just taking pictures of
these people who were there and gosh
they didn't look like
Nazis so except the one guy with the
flag as if on yeah there there was a guy
I don't think Dan took a picture of him
but he was doing these portrait I assume
that he was there to legitimize the
argument this was you know off-kilter
and then after that guy showed up um and
again we're not Canadians so we're going
to like forget all of the relevant stuff
here but um showed up at a statue of
someone who Canadians really um hold in
high esteem um members of the conf
members of the protest were there
basically guarding the statue afterwards
for the entire rest of the protest to
make sure that no idiots showed up and
did anything stupid like that again yep
um the whole
thing makes very clear the importance of
our ability to talk right or wrong
outside of these controlled narrative
streams and um I
think it is hard to overestimate the
effect that we are actually having on
History resorting to um unfettered
conversations over the internet and
therefore how important it is that we
defend our right to do that from things
like the um who pandemic preparedness
plan which actually if you're done with
this I would just briefly shift to uh to
this other topic and we are going to get
to monkey monkey monkey right yes we are
but um let's just
say those who have been following this
podcast or who saw my interview with
Tucker Carlson will know that the World
Health
Organization has been um attempting to
finalize alterations to their pandemic
preparedness plan that involve
absolutely
tyrannical uh surrender of sovereignty
that they have been plotting to um allow
anything at all to be declared a public
health emergency and then on the basis
that something is a public health
emergency to erode our ability to
discuss things in public to mandate
treatments including gene therapy it's
it's a really frightening set of
Provisions y but here's the important
part I have been getting uh murmurs that
actually we are having an effect and
that the um the pandemic preparedness
measures which were hurdling towards
ratification in uh I believe May of this
year are actually faltering this stuff
was designed not to be read we were
supposed to all think it was too
bureaucratic CO's in the past not paying
attention and because several people
including uh maybe most especially meril
nass have been tracking these changes
and calling attention uh of other covid
dissidents to it we've picked up this
story uh anyway it is now faltering so
Zack will you show that um Guardian
article so here we're showing the
guardian on I believe the
22nd um of January Global pandemic
agreement at risk of falling apart who
warns and then I'm going to keep reading
if it's big enough for me to see from
here can you scroll a little bit Yeah
would you do
that it says plans for a global pandemic
preparedness agreement risk falling
apart Amid wrangling and disinformation
according to the chief of the World
Health Organization who has warned that
future Generations quote may not forgive
us now that is an interesting claim that
we should come back to shaken by the co9
pandemic The Who 194 member states
decided more than two years ago to stop
start negot negotiating an international
Accord aimed at ensuring countries are
better equipped to deal with the next
Health catastrophe or to prevent it all
together or to prevent it altogether
interesting the plan was to steal Seal
Seal the agreement at the 20124 World
Health assembly The Who decision-making
body which convenes on the 27th of May
however
Tedros uh whose second two names are
tougher to pronounce says the who's
director General uh the who's director
General said the momentum had been
slowed down by entrenched positions and
a torrent of fake News lies and
conspiracy theory so he doesn't call us
out by name but he certainly mentions
our effect um he warned that if nobody
was prepared to seize the initiative uh
or give ground the whole project was at
risk of going
nowhere okay uh Tedros told the who's
Executive Board in Geneva on Monday time
is very short and there are several
outstanding issues that remain to be
resolved etc etc so anyway the point is
we are not so the paragraph that I see
tedro said claims that the Accord would
seed sovereignty to the who or give it
the power to impose lockdowns and
vaccine mandates were quote completely
false we spent a fair bit of time I went
I went through um one of those documents
um very very in a very detailed way and
we talked about what was in it and um
what he said there is completely false
well I so Tucker surprised me by showing
me Tedros claiming this on video that
there was no surrender of sovereignty
and I then went back later and listened
carefully to what Tedros said and it's
very interesting his claim was based on
the fact that we live in countries in
which we are represented and that they
are surrendering already seated your
sovereignty oh oh we talked about this
actually we talked about this on our
last Liv stream I think like you've
already you you live in a representative
democracy we've just taken over the
Reigns
are your representatives have seeded
your sovereignty to to us right but
here's the crazy part Tedros is now
saying well the thing is in danger of
faltering because of lies and
misinformation When In that clip what he
said was you have to get your
representatives not to do this if you
don't want your sovereignty uh eroded
that basically your representatives are
your mechanism for deciding what you do
and don't want to do and now he's
complaining about the fact that that's
what we've done
right we have exerted pressure on our
Representatives they're not interested
in signing up for this that is our
sovereignty and um he doesn't think it's
legitimate so anyway it's a fascinating
topic but really my overarching point in
showing that is we are supposed to part
of the fifth generation Warfare stuff is
that we are supposed to feel powerless
we're not powerless we're talking about
a small number of people raising the
alarm amongst large audiences using the
tools of the internet
using Twitter and Rumble and the various
tools that we are allowed to use to
spread the word and the fact is people
do care they are paying attention and we
have to keep fighting now I just one
last
caution when you get on the scale and
you see a number that you like it's not
a sign that you should start eating more
and not exercise it's a sign that you
should keep going right so the point is
this is good news if we we have to fully
derail that treaty right we cannot say
oh phew it's over for one thing these
people don't take no for an answer and
if they can't do it through the World
Health Organization they'll do it some
other way so we have to be vigilant and
when we get Goliath back on his heels we
have to keep going so that's the message
here is we are having success we are not
supposed to know that but having
discovered that we have power we need to
ex desert it and drive uh the tyrants
back into their cave
mhm all right so that's that now should
we talk about uh Panama yes I was just
trying to pull the cat into view but yes
the cat the cat all right who so rarely
shows up anymore this is Fairfax
everyone you will remember
Fairfax all right um you'll at least
remember his
ears so let's talk a little bit about um
what Zach and I saw in Panama um I
believe Zach has put together a kind of
a montage do you want to this will give
people just sort of a sense for what we
were doing we were there want bu of
stuff yeah we we were there from
the 15th to
the uh 21st yeah 15th to the all right
so we took a a trip a river trip trip to
visit one of the uh Transit
camps um in the Darian Gap so the Darian
Gap I should say is the gap in the
Pan-American Highway as the Pan-American
Highway goes from the uh Northern
reaches of North America to the southern
tip of South America there's a place
where a road has never been completed
through a uh a very dense piece of
jungle um it is not that a road could
not be completed through the Darian it
is that it has never been feasible to do
it because the jungle is effectively
ungoverned and um so we took a trip into
the Darian Gap um to watch the migrants
this is one of the migrant camps
um and uh we were able to walk through
this camp we talked to numerous migrants
uh and coming from all sorts of places
what else you
got I that's what I have prepared for
that okay um so we we also went uh
sure um we saw this remarkable
construction site this is a place where
a bridge is being installed at the end
of the paname highway this is a massive
construction project these are materials
being delivered for the completion of
this many million doll um bridge that is
being constructed for no opset going to
be a foundational pillar for this bridge
that the they are constructing out of
rebar there this is a massive project at
the end of the Pan-American Highway
leading to Nowhere leading simply to
Jungle right with no explanation did you
ask anyone yeah um we asked the foreman
of the project and his answer made it
even more mysterious he said that um The
Villages that exist beyond the end of
the Pan-American Highway in the Darian
Gap grow a lot of Yuka and Yuka is a a
rout I am particularly fond when it has
been properly fried it's very delicious
on the other hand it grows all over the
tropics there's really no reason to be
transporting huge amounts of it from the
the Darion um and even if you were going
to transport huge amounts of it from the
derian you wouldn't need a bridge this
big so um there's something remarkable
going on these people are literally
building a bridge to nowhere that they
the best they've got in terms of you
know explanations is that there might be
some desire to transport Yuka from
villages to the rest of Panama but
anyway so as I understand it um you do
not want to talk sort of a lot more
broadly here now about uh some of what
you saw in part because uh the
conversation that uh you and Chris
Martinson had at the end of the trip uh
that is now on our locals um it includes
a lot of things that U provide necessary
background to understand what is going
on yes and I will say
um it is quite hilarious to to discover
people who think they're building a
bridge to transport Yuko and that could
not possibly be what's going on um Chris
and I sort through what might be going
on and it's a lot less funny um so
anyway there's some there's obviously we
are working from an incomplete uh set of
information we are having to piece
together uh possible meanings hypotheses
from what it is that we saw that's
something that has to be done um
carefully and um anyway so yes I don't
want to um speculate wildly here I think
I think you'll be well uh it is well
worth your time to watch Chris and me
sorting through it um I me I just add
really quickly sure um we discovered a
lot of stuff on this trip uh we did a
lot of things including talking to
migrants uh which we have video of lots
of different stuff and uh stuff will be
put out in various places but if you
want to discover a lot um that we
learned from this trip going to locals
is the place to be including um like I
said those videos of migrants videos of
you talking about things and places and
um and I think maybe the two of you are
going to go on camera and talk about but
there's going to be a lot of discussion
and revealing of stuff that we that we
saw and and learned on this trip mostly
on
locals um so I guess as long as we're
here you want to show those couple of uh
I got a couple good photographs um
one in the canal not enough information
yet you're intentionally being big got
it so um okay so let's talk about this
some of you saw this on Twitter it was
put out on Twitter by some of the folks
we were with a very damp how monkey it
is a very damp how monkey hold on uh so
let me just say what happened here we
were coming back from a trip on gatun
Lake Gaton lake is the large freshwater
lake
um actually just give a little
background the French attempted to put a
canal through Panama they failed because
they didn't understand that yellow fever
and uh malaria were mosquito born and
they did foolish things like uh put
tables and beds sitting with their feet
in cups of water to prevent ants from
getting onto them which then of course
created a way for mosquitoes to breed
yep um they also had a poor plan for
making the canal
they were uh going to dig it straight
and um what the Americans realized I
think it was DPS who figured out that
the way to do it was to Dam the sh
shagas River creating a large lake which
would greatly reduce the amount of
actual digging that needed there was a
lot of dredging that needed to be done
but a lot less digging than would have
needed to be done to dig dig straight
across Panama although even so the the
little bit of digging that they did do
is called the KRA cut meaning snake and
it's it's not straight either so like
nothing that the Americans had end up
doing except for the except for the
locks at both ends are particularly
straight yeah I mean it's it's not even
it's not I didn't mean straight that way
I meant just dig dig dig rather than
create a lake which uh would allow you
know required the ships to be elevated
but uh it made the project
tractable so in any case that um
situation is pretty interesting now uh
almost 3 million years ago something
like 2.7 million years ago nor and South
America were connected by the ismos of
Panama which the geological evidence
suggest Rose from the sea and of
course is it's like a 12 million year
prence it's that moment of like 2.8 is
million years ago it's like the end of
like 12 million year process which
involves both you know drift and and
uplift um it resulted bi biotically in
creatures moving in both directions and
uh interestingly the pattern with was
not halfhazard with respect to which
competitors won out in this it's called
the Great funnel interchange and it's a
it's a pretty interesting story but um
just say that uh when the Great interf
final interchange happened on land and
you know rejoicing in the land um what
happened in the Seas was the great
schism the great schism and uh because
these waterways between the Caribbean
the Atlantic and the Pacific which had
always been open were now closed and um
there's some remarkably excellent
research actually on on um because we
can actually date the moment of the land
bridge forming um very precisely uh we
can actually figure out differences in
um in um Evolution Gene Evolution
organismal Evolution gene flow in the
marine organisms on both sides and the
fact that we terrestrial biologists view
this as a great FAL interchange suggests
that we are suffering from a certain
amount of
schisis yeah discrimination against the
Schism of the Seas yes um now
interestingly though in 1913 when the
canal was completed it reinstated a
division between North and South America
there is no land Crossing other than
well when I was there uh doing my work
and you were there as well there was one
Bridge you've been back to Panama since
then I haven't been back yeah I think
when I did my study abroad there in the
mids um and early teens I I thought that
there was still just the bridge of them
the Americas but I I may have missed it
because we weren't hanging out in the
Canal Zone mostly there are at least now
two more bridges um but nonetheless
these are not ways that a creature is
likely you know creature in four lanes
of traffic that's not not how it's done
so um so anyway the the creation of the
Panama Canal basically reinstituted a
Schism between North and South America
and interestingly Al yeah this seems
seemed impossible it is also even though
the Canal is elevated above sea level on
both sides um facilitating the exchange
of sea life between the Pacific and the
Caribbean um and do we know is that is
that like Stow ways on boats or is that
is that moving in with the locks there
has been some stowaway there's been some
bwat stuff um but this is actually
apparently creatures being pulled in um
behind boats and the surprising thing
about it is since the canal is
freshwater you would think that uh most
ocean creatures wouldn't tolerate it but
apparently there are now uh ocean fish
being routinely pulled out of the canal
by
fishermen and uh there's also uh uh
saltwater intrusion which is a problem
because the freshwater for Panama City
largely comes from the canal but anyway
so many problems yeah I digress though
so we were coming back from a trip uh on
Gaton Lake out to Bar Colorado Island
which is uh where I did Bat work um and
uh I was sitting in the front of the
boat kind of waiting to see birds and I
realized there's something in the water
and I said what's that you to show now
uh Matt said I don't know Matt was uh
one of the people who was with us on
this trip and we diverted the boat to go
look at it um and it turned out to be
something uh I had never seen before and
nobody else present had seen before
which was a monkey swimming across the
canal you want to so here's that monkey
talk over this um so this is a howler
monkey the canal is way too wide for
he's got an Otter Tail doesn't he yeah
um anyway you can see him swimming and
you'll get some sense here in a minute
or two how far he has to go the canal is
way too wide it'd be difficult to you
could do it as a person but um much
harder as a as an arboreal yeah so again
the canal here is a lake it's people
imagine the canal is is like is locks
all the way through and as we watching
this monkey go here this uh I think it's
a freighter um came cruising through and
just barely missed the monkey and you
can see how delayed his Transit yeah you
so we've it pushed the monkey aside do
with any exactly anyway but he was he
was moving towards the shore and the
monkey basically gave up and stopped
swimming after that boat had passed and
this guy had a net in his boat we we
were reluctant to pick the monkey up
because there a very good chance of get
a bit but um anyway this guy had a net
and he put him in a tree now I find this
whole thing fascinating and it's almost
impossible for me not to see it in
symbolic terms right I mean for one
thing this monkey's habitat was divided
by a canal put in in 1913 and that means
that habitat that a monkey like this
used to be able to uh Transit even in
the Treetops is now something that he
has to contemplate swimming to get
across now what would motivate him you
know how bad do things have to be
wherever he was to motivate that these
waters are are crocodile infested um
when you and I were there we used to
swim regularly and the crocodiles um
with one notable exception did not
harass people unless you got between
them and their nest their nest of babies
um that is apparently no longer the case
the crocodiles are now uh they kill
people somewhat regularly and people no
longer swim there um and this monkey was
swimming in a place that is apparently
dense with crocodiles um but is it Poss
I mean you don't know um but it's
possible it wasn't a choice like that I
it's hard to tell when a monkey is wet
and there was very little there for
scale but he sort of looked little for a
howler I thought so too he looked young
um and you know he looked bedraggled but
that's just because he was um but but he
could have fallen out of a tree and then
s of been disoriented and not not
realized what way to go I'm pretty sure
he was well oriented because um as we
stopped to look at him other boats saw
our behavior and came in and started
looking at him too and he didn't start
spinning in place or something he just
they kept they kept spit their action
disoriented him and then he kept
reorienting towards the shore on the
other side ining us we kept getting in
his way too he knew which way he was
going okay and after the big ship yeah
um and but anyway
the it is there's something about
watching this
animal who is in a newly unnatural
habitat that Canal is a profound feature
of the landscape obviously I I came to
think of it as like an aorta of the
world economy and actually it's even
more so than uh when we were there
because the Canal has been upgraded and
improved and the amount of cargo that is
capable of moving through this thing is
absolutely stunning so you've got a huge
fraction of the world's economic activi
passing through this canal and this
monkey who world has been divided by it
is now confronted by these immense ships
um so anyway it
does it does in some way mirror all of
our predicament right we're living in an
unnatural World um in which forces that
are almost too big to consider um have
profound impacts on on our ability to to
just even simply operate our our program
and do whatever it is we should be doing
um anyway so I thought here we are
narrowly missing being plowed under by
giant entities that we're not of our
choosing totally and you know it's hard
to convey what it was like to look at
this ship like I I took a lot of
photographs none of them good because
except the one of the monkey at the
beginning here but it was very hard how
do you capture if you capture the ship
it's a spe the monkey do and if you
capture the monkey then it's like you
know some weird background but this the
the difference in scale is too immense
to convey photographically absolutely um
but it was also um interesting to watch
you know this animal is a migrant and um
in some ways his predicament isn't that
different than um people crossing the
perilous Darian gap for you know because
wherever they're fleeing from conditions
are bad enough that it is worth
contemplating uh that Journey um we have
some other stuff to show as long as
we're
here yeah um so we'll just show a few
photos
to give people a sense of what we were
looking at
um so this was on our River Journey
that's a corant that is caught a catfish
that's so cool we saw lots of um that's
your photograph yep we saw lots of
indigenous people actually spearing
catfish I've never seen this before
people with masks and Spears masks yeah
just by the side of the the river
spearing fish so they'd be like in
they'd be looking underwater with their
masks and then they come up and
typically they would look at us through
their masks go back to how were they
they were hunting with their eyes
underwater exactly exactly pretty muddy
water y
interesting um all right so here's me
with one of the ca front guys the
senafront is the uh the part of the
Panamanian government um that is charged
with um guarding the Border I will point
out this is you and C front guide dress
uh incredibly warmly for 90° weather
with sun you know yeah I did I did think
he looked awfully comfortable for a guy
wearing as much as he was in that heat
but any I mean we were all just soaking
our t-shirts thoroughly with sweat again
okay all right uh oh here's the lock of
the Panama Canal which i' never gone
through the Panama Canal before I've
lived in it but I never gone through the
lock so this was a pretty cool
experience there's Zach and me before
the lock bills we're sort of moving in
the the small ships that you can um
Transit the canal in get tucked in with
the big ships so that water is not
wasted in the in the
transit oh here I saw an osprey uh catch
something
probably I'm not actually sure what it
was but um anyway I thought that was a
nice photo and a good shot um it's
really nice so anyway uh if you're
interested in more about our conclusions
from that trip definitely go over to
locals um we will talk about conclusions
from that trip more in uh in the future
um here and elsewhere so anyway stay
tuned and I think that's all I got all
right well I think uh I think we've
arrived then at the end so um yeah just
to hit it one more time check you know
go over to locals please please join us
there there's been a watch party going
on now we've got our Discord community
over there and we released guest
episodes early there before they are
released to the public um but you know
right now in um in the wake of this trip
uh that Brett and Zach took uh into the
Canal Zone and the Daren in Panama with
Michael yon and Chris Mar and a few
others um there's just already there's a
release of some very important stuff
there and uh we encourage you to join us
there yeah let me just I'll add one more
thing I forgot to say um what we are
really navigating in that uh discussion
that Chris and I had is the question of
whether or not this is an invasion um of
the US what why there is such a large
Chinese component to it and these are
things that need to be thought about
very carefully but anyway that's all
discussed in that
video yeah I I guess um since you just
said that the thing that has been most
surprising to me about hearing not just
from you but from others who are
eyewitness to what has been happening is
um that it is not entirely or even in
many places largely Latin Americans who
are who are coming across the border yes
there are many Latin Americans but the
degree to which this is somehow a global
phenomenon that starts uh actually in
Ito Ecuador for a lot of them uh tells a
different story there's some something a
foot yeah
indeed all right um so join us there um
also actually this Sunday on locals
we'll have have our monthly private Q&A
uh so uh at 11:00 a.m. Pacific for 2
hours and uh open now is the question
asking uh period for that uh but you can
also get to on
locals um gosh I guess lots of other
stuff but um check out our wonderful
sponsors this week that was moink seed
and paleo Valley we'll have links to
everything we talked about in the show
notes and a reminder that we are
supported by you our audience um given
that we're going to be putting a bunch
of good stuff up on locals an easy way
to support us is to go over and join
join on locals uh and uh and and find us
there uh so until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well
[Music]
everyone